what do you think about this whole idea
of
safe spaces uh on college campuses
because it feels like the
the mission of librex is pushing back
against the idea of safe spaces
i think safe spaces are fine when
they're within people's private lives
within their homes you know within their
religious organizations
i think the problem becomes when the
institution starts encouraging
or um backing safe spaces
because what are people being safe from
and oftentimes it seems like there's
this idea that
the harm that's being attempted to to be
mitigated is the harm of confronting
opinions you disagree with opinions you
might find repugnant right
and if this is conflated with a need for
safety
then that's where the idea of liberal
arts education sort of dies
of course it's complicated and we still
want to have safe intellectual
environments
but the way that i hear the term safe
space used today
i think it doesn't really have a place
within
like the intellectual context yeah
it's funny i mean this is why librex is
really exciting is it's pushing those
difficult conversations and i'd love to
see
ultimately there does seem to be an
asymmetry of power
that results in the concept of safe
spaces and
hate speech being redefined in a
slippery slope kind of way where it
means basically anything you want it to
mean
and uh it basically is used to silence
people
to silence people they're like good
thoughtful
experts also beyond that i would say it
has
not just a pragmatic purpose which is
the silencing
but also sort of an ideological purpose
which is a linguistic purpose which is
to
conflate words with unsafety
and harm and violence which is what
you kind of see on a cultural linguistic
level is happening
all around us right now is that this
idea that words are harm
it's a very dangerous and slippery
concept i mean
it's not you don't have to slip that far
to see why that's a problem
once we start crim making words into
violence and we start criminalizing
words we get into
some really authoritarian territory
things that i think
i mean myself and my background i don't
know how much we have to go into it but
uh
things in my that my ancestors certainly
would be worried about
what's your background i'm a child of
holocaust survivors and program
survivors
so yeah i mean me as well from different
directions that come from the soviet
union so
there's uh well like in most of us
hate and love uh runs through our blood
from our history
you